[Music]
Dylan it's fabulous to be here with you
today thank you so much yeah thank you
so Dylan I want to start by talking
about the very beginning how did you get
involved in gaming yeah I um I just
picked up fortnite in you know 2017 when
it came out it was the first game that I
really got invested into yeah um me and
my buddies we all play to just like hang
out and play every night um it really
kind of transitioned though from like
gaming in like the gamer sense to like
more of the like creating sense when
they released their like creative
platform in you know 2018 um and that's
where I kind of like picked up doing
more of the creative and development
side of things because more interesting
to me and um I was able to just be
creative and you know do use my
imagination and a lot of people don't
know exactly what user generated content
is and how that applies to you and what
you're doing can you explain that a bit
for audiences who aren't so familiar
yeah yeah so user generated content is
basically like um anybody who even a
player or somebody who's not even
familiar with like game development can
get in and and develop games and um it's
not really backed by Studios necessarily
and and epic games or the big studios
aren't like developing it themselves so
anybody can get in to ugc and um you
know see if they can find their footing
in in that in that space so then you
were and correct me if I'm wrong then
creating a your own kind of experience
and game within the fortnite world how
does that work okay yeah so they offered
this platform um the ugc fortnite
creative platform and you know I was
doing Battle Royale for a while just
playing it and having fun but I've
always had hobbies and I've always had
like you know side hustles um so when
you know creative released I just got
dug into it and then tried to like it
was it was very simple at the time so I
was able to like kind of pick things up
slowly and teach myself um how you know
how to make a game very cool and talk to
me about the business side of that so do
people pay you to play that or how does
how does the revenue Share work there
it's it's interesting um the revenue
share like we can't sell anything in
games um we only just try to attract
people to our games to like play we try
to get them to play as long as possible
and you know epic monetizes that through
their this model that came out probably
six months ago um where we're paid based
on our play time and the amount of
players that we have and stuff like that
so we can't sell anything yet um we
can't directly monetize but we get to uh
have a cut of like what epic brings
through their item shop and through
whatever they're selling so you started
that's a very entrepreneurial thing
within just kind of every Niche group
yeah then how did you go from I know you
were a nurse how did you then go from
that to the company that you're building
today tell me about that Journey oh my
gosh um while I was a nurse I was I was
first in the trauma ICU um and then when
covid came around I was switched into
the co ICU um which ended up being it
was it was it was an experience for sure
um I started to get like a little bit
burned out after like six seven months
of that I was like throwing my back out
I couldn't walk every like two months so
I was like knowing that I needed to
change and um I had been doing fortnite
on the side just as a little hobby kind
of thing and so around May of
20121 um I decided like I'm going to
take a month off from nursing kind of
just like regroup and like get myself
back on track and a week after I decided
to do that um epic games they hit me up
they' messaged me and said um hey we
really like your stuff we want you to
help us develop some concerts for us so
I was like okay I'll take four or five
months off from nursing and explore that
and then um about a week after that uh a
legendary YouTube gamer named Alia uh he
messaged me and he was like Hey like
your stuff um would you help me develop
games so that was kind of like the
signal that I needed to like fully jump
into this um and after about 3 four
months of just doing it full-time I
started to like like be able to identify
like where players would want to play
and it led me to launching some games
that have gotten pretty successful and
helped me to um want to create like
something bigger and that's kind of how
it led to me forming a company and
trying to trying to grow that way what
are some of those games that you created
that are so big today um the biggest one
uh currently is called go goed um it's
basically like on fortnite's platform
it's it's teams of four um and four
teams they kind of just battle it out to
be the last team standing um it's simple
it's fast-paced and and players come
back and have fun very cool so now talk
to me about your new company name of it
and what you're doing yeah so it's
called um good Gamers um the idea behind
it is like we wanted to approach uh the
development side of games from like a
more of like a marketing and and
organization focused so we have good
Gamers and those are our marketing and
influen ERS and content creators and we
bring them into the team because they
are the people who can reach a lot of
people um and so they're awesome they're
helping us build a community um but then
on the on the back end we have you know
people like me and a couple others uh
that I've brought on who are the good
who develop the good games um so it's
like good Gamers good games GG's because
ggs is what a lot of like Gamers say
like after they finish playing so what
is does it just mean G good game yeah
just means good game yep very cool okay
I got to use that next time I play Mario
Kart yay yeah so are you is your
competition then like the epic games of
the world or who would you say is your
competition and how are you standing out
um that's a good question I mean it's
it's a very competitive space um there's
people all over the world because it's
user generated content people all over
the world are developing games there's
you know any anyone from like 18 to
people in their 60s developing games on
this platform and everybody has
different skill sets too so me not
coming from like a formal game
development background um I've trying
been trying to like pick things up
really quickly and and trying to like
figure out who I should work with to
help us become more competitive and and
maintain a Competitive Edge in that
space um and we are competing with epic
technically now as well since you know
they have their Battle Royale game and
then we also have the creative side of
things that we're you know kind of
sharing players and ask some players
back and forth too yeah do you are you
nervous about going up against these
these bigger incumbents yeah a little
bit I mean um I just like not so much
nervous but like just want to kind of
stay focused on what I what I believe
like is going to be like our next big
games and like what our you know what
we're doing with our influencers and our
developers and our community that we're
building so um not so much nervous just
like want to do it properly yeah yeah
that makes sense and speaking of
influencers and creators how are you
using you know the social media and and
cre Creer economy to help Propel your
business well I I use it myself a lot I
have um you know YouTube and Tik Tok and
stuff like that and I have I use Tik Tok
all the time to Market um my own stuff
or my team stuff so I have like 400,000
followers there and so that's helped me
to like reach a lot of people there but
on top of that like every single person
that we have on the team um they all
have this unique like group of followers
that you know somebody has like a
million on on Twitter somebody has has
millions on YouTube or on you know Tik
Tok and stuff so everybody's kind of
like coming together to like bring our
games to different communities of
players which has been really cool very
cool and you've taken on no outside
funding correct not yet no how has that
been then building a business just
bootstrapping it yeah it's it's been
interesting I mean I I'm very blessed to
have the game that I have um that I
mentioned go goed and that one has
hovered you know as one of the top games
for a while um and so it has been able
to fund like these ideas that i' I've
wanted to kind of implement and you know
kind of like you said bootstrapping like
I have something successful but I want
to bring on you know 10 15 people and
I'm just I'm lucky to be able to do that
with you know what what I have would you
be open to taking on VC investments in
the future or is that something you want
to stay away from no I'm definitely
interested in it um I'm definitely I'm
learning a lot about it as well um and
definitely would be interested in it I
would want to make sure that if I did
accept money like I'd want to know and
like be very confident in like what I
was going to be able to use it for and
like how I was going to implement it um
to help us grow and scale up and stuff
like that totally and I want to get a
sense of the the scale of your business
are you able to talk to me about users
or customers or anything of that sort
yeah um well we since we can't sell
anything we don't have customers yet but
we have we have plenty of users um the
game go- goed that one reaches between
800,000 and a million players every day
um and has over 750 million plays total
um and then for our team we're we're
doing really well as well we've we
launched like six or seven months ago
and we already have I think four games
that are totaling over 500,000 players a
day W so we've we've reached over a 100
million unique players since I started
in 20 like early 2020 wow yeah so it's
kind of it's kind of grown a lot
definitely growing what has been the
most challenging part of running your
company
um there's a lot of challenges um you
know it's players are playing all day
all around the world um and we're on a
platform where you know we are
developing in line with like epic as
they're developing as well so kind of
like being available at all times and
being ready to kind of like jump in fix
a game that might break um or kind of
using the ecosystem in the best way for
example we may push updates at 3:00 a.m.
um so I'll be like setting my alarm
waking up and and pushing an update at
3:00 a.m. because there's not a lot of
people playing at that time and if
something's broken we have to be able to
fix it so I think um you know that
that's one of the challenges is kind of
being available all the time um other
challenges are just like it's just a
learning curve um when I started four
years ago it was it was more simple but
now epic's given us like the entire tool
set that they use for Unreal Engine
which is used by big studios and mov mov
and animation companies and all that
stuff so it's got a lot of tools and so
we've just been like fast-paced like
trying to learn everything and trying to
implement things in the right way to you
know give players the best experience
interesting so now where do you see this
company going in the future because
you've worked independently to create a
game you now have a company what's next
for you what's next for the company um
yeah I think we are going to definitely
look at like scaling up um right now
we're we have a lot of uh we have a few
of us doing a lot of stuff and so
ideally we want to bring on some new new
people to the team to help kind of
offload some of this work and um and
allow us to scale up in a way that you
know nobody's overworking themselves or
nobody's like you know getting burnt out
or anything like that yeah um and then
on top of that I mean there's a lot of
people in this gaming space where I
would like to be able to invest in them
as well um and see you know I've had
some people bring me this these ideas
and I think it's a great idea and coming
from like being a nurse not formally a
game developer um when somebody brings
me an idea that I think you know is
their vision for what they want to do um
I think it's cool to be in a position
where I could potentially like partner
with them or like work with them to like
help them you know make that happen for
themselves too so I think we'll try to
do that yeah yeah I think that's a great
idea do you think that there's ever a
World in which you'd consider selling
your company maybe to an epic or an AC
Blizzard or something like that and if
so what would it take oh my gosh um yeah
it's tough I mean I've been approached
before um about it and uh the the hard
part about it is it's like it's like my
baby like I put like so much time and
effort into it over the past you know
two three years um so it's hard to let
go of um but at the end of the day like
I'm also open to business and stuff like
that so so as long as I knew that a
company was going to come in and they
had the right assets and they had the
right ideas and you know they were going
to take care of it and help it to grow
like you know that that that would kind
of be what I would look at awesome yeah
is there one business rule that you
always operate by no matter what um
honestly yeah like my kind of like what
I like to do is I like to do right by
people so I work with a lot of people a
lot of like younger people are less like
uh they're not like Professionals in
what they do and so sometimes people
like hey I'll do this for you I'll do
that for you and I'm like no like
anybody who works for me like I got to
make sure like you are compensated like
however you need to be and I think
that's like helped us to grow like in a
way that like people trust like what I'm
doing and what what we're doing as a
team um and it's opened a lot of doors
with you know who we've gotten to work
with amazing now some of the things I
hear from the older generation whoes
doesn't quite understand you know the
gaming space is that you know this is
just a hobby this is not a career and
I'm sure you've probably heard that from
a lot of people in your life um how do
how you dealt with that and do you have
any any advice for people in the gaming
industry who are dealing with that
that's a good question I mean it was a
it is a hobby for a lot of people um but
I think just like with so many hobbies
like if you are passionate about
something and you are you know a little
bit Savvy like you can turn a hobby or
passion or whatever into a business for
yourself so um I mean my answer to that
would be like this space has hundreds of
millions of people playing like a year
like every year every day millions and
millions of players and it's constantly
growing so
um it's it can be more than a hobby if
you want it to be yeah excellent
anything else that's exciting uh in the
pipeline that you could share with us
that's coming up in 2024 2024 yeah um I
mean I think we're going to continue to
build our communities build our um build
our games out and we really want to like
grow uh our footprint in like the
fortnite creative space
um not just in the gaming sense but like
in the entire like Community sense so um
as we're gr we're looking for people to
partner with to help us have more like
social profile or more like business
front so like can we you know do merch
um can we can we build like Brands
around our games and kind of like scale
those games up to be almost like uh
bespoke games that are like their own
entity not not necessarily like a
fortnite fortnite creative game but like
its own thing um so I think that's kind
of where we're going to try and take it
and just try to like build small teams
around each of these games and try to
grow as we go what are some of your
favorite games besides fortnite that you
grew playing um I have a lot of
nostalgia uh for some games so stuff
like Super Mario World um on the Super
Nintendo um Luigi's Mansion um Donkey
Kong games like that because I I played
all those grown up and me and my friends
we have a lot of great memories from you
know sitting in my basement doing that
um and then I kind of stepped away from
gaming for you know
high school and stuff like that played
soccer and stuff so coming back into it
like I look back on those games I'm like
man we had such a such a good time
playing those we were like six or seven
you know so it's really hard to go from
just being a a nurse to then taking the
dive into entrepreneurship was there one
specific thing that convinced you that
you could do it and what advice would
you have for people facing similar
situations yeah I think um that's a lot
of a lot of people who want to get into
this like they probably face that as
well and so I think um for
myself it there's a point that you get
to where you're like I think this is the
right thing to do this is something that
I believe in and your kind of like fear
or your fear of the unknown is like
holding you back so it kind of is just
like that point where I'm going to
commit to something and I'm I'm not
going to look back um and for me that
was when I decided I'm not going to
renew my nursing license I'm going to
just commit to what I'm doing and I'm
going to give it my all um and I think
the other thing with that is like you
know talking to the people that you're
close with and and telling them your
vision and telling them and they can
probably see how like passionate you can
be about something so um for me that was
my wife she was very very supportive of
me um when I was like sitting on a bar
stool in our in our living room making
these games on my PlayStation um she
didn't really give me like any like push
back just supported me through it and
it's changed our lives so yeah say just
like be confident in yourself um and
have a Clear Vision of what you want and
then you just have to take that that
step take that leap leap of faith and
commit to it and um good things can come
from that great and last one for you
what would you like your legacy to be oh
that's a good question um I think I'd
like my legacy just like to be you know
with my friends family and you know
people who know me personally um just
that I was like a supportive
like role in their lives and like a good
like person to you know
I guess be friends with you know I think
the thing is like most people uh know me
for my games they don't really know me
um which I'm happy to I'm happy to have
that because if I'm giving them good
experiences I think my legacy I'd like
for those people to be you know when
they look back 20 years from now they
look back the way I did on the games
that I grew up with and they say wow
like we met some really great people
maybe made some lifelong friends through
the games that you know I've developed
and it's happened a few times I've I've
run into some people who have met and
have these great memories from the games
that like I've had a hand in making
that's awesome thank you so much Dylan I
appreciate it than
[Music]
you